جنود اوكرانيين التحقوا بمراكز التدريب
العسكري في بولندا لتعلم كيفيه تشغيل
دبابات الالمانيه لصد الهجوم الروسي تدريب
يمتد لشهر ومدته 10 ساعات على الاقل في
اليوم الواحد تحت اشراف مدربين بولنديين
ونرويجيين
نحن لسنا في حاجه الى تحفيزهم بل مرافقتهم
وتعليمهم انهم متحمسون جدا للوصول الى
المستوى المطلوب من المهارات والمعرفه
تدريب الجنود الاوكرانيين يتم في جنوب غرب
بولندا في قاعده عسكريه وعلى نفس المركبات
المدرعه التي ستشكل معداتهم المستقبليه
على امل منهم ان تغير الدبابات الالمانيه
قواعد اللعبه في ساحه المعركه
اعتقد ان هذه الاسلحه ستكون ذات فائده
كبيره لجيشنا بمجرد ان نتقن كيفيه
استخدامها خاصه في جبهات القتال اظن ان
تاثيرها سيكون هائلا
الرئيس البولندي كان حاضرا في القاعده
العسكريه للقاء القوات الاوكرانيه التي
جاءت مباشره من خط المواجهه
هؤلاء الجنود كانوا يقاتلون في ساحه
المعركه قبل ايام قليله فقط انظروا الى
وجوههم يمكنكم ان ترى انهم اعانوا من
اشياء مروعه
وارسو واحده من ابرز حلفائكيف وقد دفعت
الدول الاوروبيه لتزويد اوكرانيا بدبابات
القتال الحديثه
ووعدت كل من بولندا والمانيا بارسال ما لا
يقل عن اربع عشره دبابه 2 الى اوكرانيا
ومن البلدان الاخرى المساهمه في هذه
العمليه النرويج والدنمارك وهولندا